good morning millennials happy friday
welcome back to the morning toast
our final show in studio before we take
a hiatus for the month of august we are
so excited
honored blessed and humbled to be here
with you one final time
we are this is gonna be spanish such an
exciting fabulous show i'm so so excited
for a vacation but i would be
rdh i would have that funny feeling in
my stomach if i didn't just express
the love that i have for the show and
the community and it's been a crazy few
months for everyone across the board
unprecedented times as they say
absolutely um
but i personally couldn't have gotten
through without this show
without everyone who has stuck by us and
and continues to love and watch the show
and
we love doing it so it's been an
integral part of
our mental health and i hope that it has
been for you
and it's just been a crazy time i hope
everyone is really just
doing the best that they can in the
current circumstances it
it ain't easy out here for anyone so we
hope that you're just finding time for
yourself and that this little pocket of
peace
as my favorite tick tock nobella says i
hope you're just finding little pockets
of peace in your day and doing
all that you can to not go crazy
exactly but other than that wow i can't
believe it's
friday friday gotta get down on friday
speaking of i was on tick tock this
morning and on my favorite page one of
this
one of these videos popped up that went
viral and it was a rebecca black video
she's like an influencer now um but she
did like a whole 60 second video on her
experience doing friday cause she gets
asked all the time like okay
would you regret it and she was speaking
so vague and so generally like i didn't
know what what exactly she was referring
to
but i guess she got like bullied a lot
online because the video was
like viral but people were making fun of
it that way yeah people were making fun
of it mostly
and basically what she said which was
actually like really profound thing and
she said she's been in therapy like a
lot since then
that um like try not to be mad at your
younger self for like making decisions
like you
you can't control it and like even
though you were like dumb and weird and
back then like
that's who you are so like try not to
hate yourself but honestly i felt that
very deeply wow that really strikes a
chord i know
and it's it's so true because it's like
obviously she looks back on that video
and she's like why did i do that except
i don't think she feels that way because
she's famous now and she wouldn't be and
i think she actually has a pretty nice
career for herself
yeah but i'm sure you cringe at your own
yourself but it's like your younger self
was just living her best life and sure
like
it's not the choices you would make now
but she was just trying to get through
no a hundred percent and i just thought
that was like a really interesting take
on it and i wanted to share
no i really that really resonates with
me thank you for sharing claudia that's
beautiful because i feel like we all
like look back on certain times in our
lives like certain things we wore
certain things we said
and like we just hate ourselves because
we're like so embarrassed by the people
that we used to be i'm very embarrassed
by the person i used to be
you've blocked her out and i have like
so much shame and like i hate her
and hearing rebecca black say that i was
like why do i hate myself like and it
was really
i don't know it was like a fabulous
thing to wake up to no it's really
it's really important to remember and i
i remember when we were it was the end
of the year and we were doing our
decade recap and our year recap and this
conversation came up a lot
uh when we were thinking back to like
2010 and
we were in high school then and we were
just like
full of shame so much and it's just like
yes it's a little embarrassing
but she made you who you are and you
love yourself and i
i couldn't agree more like i think i'm
so fabulous now and i don't think i
would be this fabulous if i wasn't a
monster 10 years ago so
it's all good it's not nice to her no i
know it's all good it's something i'm
like really really dealing with like
this shame that i feel
so i'm i'm working on it but hearing
rebecca black going through the same
thing like made me feel seen
yeah no that makes me feel very seen as
well and by the way those episodes that
i'm talking about are available on our
patreon channel patreon.com
morning toast where we talk about all of
the big plans that we had for this year
that obviously did not come to fruition
and it's never been a better time to
become a patreon member since we are
going on hiatus reminder
we are switching to weekly episodes
starting next week for the next five
weeks so you get five weekly episodes
every wednesday
we'll still be doing deer toasters just
recapping the fast five of the entire
week as opposed to the entire day
plus all the real housewives because we
have beverly hills new york and potomac
on right now
and um chatting like we do
right so patreon will be pertinent for
the month of august because then you'll
get five extra episodes there five
weekly episodes then you got double the
amount of episodes
7.99 for five extra episodes from jackie
and i per month
vlog episodes um podcast episodes and
then you also get access to the facebook
group which is for members only so it's
7.99
head over to patreon.com check it out
love it sign on get premium content by
the way did you notice that
i got a haircut you know i didn't notice
because it looks exactly the same
well so what i asked for that's that's
kind of what i wanted i wanted to keep
the length but get a lot of light
i'm sorry it's just like choking it's
emotional but get a lot of layers
because i've been wearing my hair kind
of straight on the show mostly because i
don't have the time to curl it
and it looks kind of it just hangs there
and i kind of look like i'm in a cult
and so this just gives it a little bit
more natural body
it looks great and it's also like you
know i just kind of like
like mom haircuts yeah so these are
this is my new look i read a tweet over
the weekend that like fully attacked me
oh really yeah it was like grown women
over 25 like stop having long hair
i'm like excuse me if you stop having
long hair don't tell me what to do
that's so interesting like is that is
that a common way of thinking
so i think a co that's a very extreme
tweet i think a common way of thinking
if we're
playing on age tropes in society which
you know i
hate to do the face of ageism right here
is that having
long hair is a very young look so when
you're older
you shouldn't have like super long hair
i think they're
i didn't know the limit was 25 i was
thinking like 70
right but that is
sort of a thing that young long hair is
a much younger look
and you know how people have like i want
to talk to the manager here that's
when they're old enough to talk to a
manager like just yet another impossible
beauty standard for women
an impossible age standard like who can
even keep up with these standards
they're confused
and these rules like i gotta get a
notebook and start writing them down
yeah somebody to keep up with so many to
keep up with but my hair is the longest
that it's ever been
and i just wanted to keep it that way
for a while but what's crazy is i got a
haircut the week before we went into
quarantine
and i was so excited about it because i
was like my hair is going to grow this
entire time and like that's exactly what
happened it's almost six months later
and i had to get another haircut even
though it feels like i just got one and
you have nothing to show for your
haircut like your first one
oh like you don't get to take your
haircut anywhere yes but the growth that
i experienced
and like the length my hair was
yesterday on this show or no i was
wearing a bun two days ago
is what i have to show for it because it
would never have grown that much if it
wasn't so healthy at the beginning
true i just can't believe that like
i'm feeling very full circle so i just
can't believe like when we started
quarantine
and like where we are now we're
literally first of all in a different
space i know
we um i have gained like so much weight
um i have absolutely like accomplished
nothing in the last six months
i have crippling anxiety it's just it's
really amazing what six months can do
it's amazing what six months can do but
here i i've got to just
look on the bright side for you because
you're incapable of it and i just want
to say
on monday's episode i was feeling in a
particularly good mood and i think i was
the most positive i'd ever been and i
never got more messages about how weird
i was on the show
everyone was like is she okay she was a
lot today so you know what
i'm back to being negative that's what
you guys want easy you got it
okay here's the bright side first of all
you've made it through you've made it
this far
and honestly it's it's a challenge yes
you've gotten up every day you've done
this show
and it's been fabulous you're putting
smiles on people's faces that's true
you've accomplished that you've given
people something to look forward to
you've taken care of your little man
that's the most important and he's
extremely well adjusted for the
quarantine
extremely i think he was actually made
for the quarantine considering how much
he just
loves to stay at home he is agoraphobic
um
also you look beautiful sunny and smart
so i do feel like
of the people that i know you are doing
the best
you said that to me the other night and
it's just because like
everyone i know was doing so badly no
yes technically i do thrive in
agoraphobic situations like i really
the whole staying at home thing doesn't
bother me it's just like the
the atmosphere like the climate like the
way people have been speaking to one
another and like even my tick tock it's
just like videos of people like
in parking lots in like walmart's like
getting in fights over face masks like
just this climate is like killing me
like this hostility and like
we've never been more divided and you
know me i'm i stand firmly in the middle
on almost everything so it's like it's
killing me
it's killing me and it's like i thought
before quarantine like
you know we were a country divided but
now i just feel like everyone [ __ ]
hates each other
and the way they speak to each other
even like even in our comment section on
instagram like
the way people speak to each other it's
just crazy and like that is that's what
i hate like i can't stand that's like
the
the thing that's been bothering me the
most is just like how did we get here
yeah
remember when dr burks was on our show
and at the beginning she was like what's
really been amazing about all this is
like everyone from both sides of the
aisle from private to public sector has
really come together
to want to help during this pandemic and
like we just went so downhill from that
moment like when she said it she like
cursed it
because the opposite is now and like
that's just type of you know
this climate just gives me anxiety
that's what it is yeah you're not alone
in that
i know you are not alone i think a lot
of people feel that way i think a lot of
people watch the show feel that way
and i don't know what to tell you
because i feel the same way
it's really like scary and that's really
why i'm looking forward to the hiatus
just to like
unplug from that toxicity and like i
wish i was the type of person who could
just like throw my phone to the other
side of the bed
and like not be on it but first of all
it's my job second of all i have an
addiction
so it's like i'm forcing myself to like
put i put myself forcibly like in the
center of all this
toxicity and it's just bad so i'm really
looking forward to
taking some time off like i i want to
take a break from so much of our job is
like knowing what's going on in the
world and it's very heavy
yeah and i just want a little bit like a
a second timeout
i think that's very very fair and i
think it's important for everyone to
take time
like that for yourselves if you feel
that you need it yes so
fabulous yeah it's i concur so i think
we should just give the best damn show
they've ever had in their [ __ ] lives
best damn show i have so much to give
today oh good okay i think it's my
haircut
and i like my outfit a haircut really
does add a little um to
a little bounce in your step let's do it
okay
without further ado it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and i know some people may have
forgotten but it is still technically
summer and you still
do need to look fabulous and that's why
i'm so excited it's friday we are
highlighting a black owned business and
today is arrow and phoenix
kayla bell arrow and phoenix's founder
at just seven years old displayed a love
for design with a keen eye for detail
that has since taken her places she
never could have imagined when she was
in middle and high school she found that
as a 38 triple d
cup finding a comfortable swimsuit top
that wasn't created with someone else's
grandmother
in mind was nearly impossible so she
began creating her own
arrow in phoenix was born with bold
colors 90s influence styles and
comfortable silhouettes
by an owner who prides herself on
providing only the best of quality
with its wide variety of sizes arrow in
phoenix offers the bikini that would
give the shyest woman the
self-confidence to talk to the hottest
guy at the pool bar
it will inspire the hardest-working 24
year old law student to let her hair
down every once in a while
and that her bikinis would always be
tied to some wild memory of a
bachelorette party everyone remembers
but vowed to never speak
again the arrow in phoenix mission is
simple to empower women
give back and provide luxurious creative
and comfortable swimwear that celebrates
having a good time
arrow in phoenix's swimwear is
sustainable swimwear brand created by a
self-proclaimed beach bum who wanted to
invite other millennials into her world
of fashion and sustainable living
they offer comfortable supportive and
luxuriously sexy swimwear made from
recycled materials
which take 70 percent less energy to
manufacture arrow and phoenix's pieces
are handcrafted in los angeles with
pieces that range from brock
sizes a to h they also offer skin care
products including the skin
silk bronzing oil while the bronzing oil
gives the best glow and smells great
most importantly it is great for your
skin
they blend all the blend of these
specific oils keeps your skin firm
clear and moisturized the aloe vera oil
keeps your skin from getting sunburned
and almond oil with add added 24 carat
gold clusters
will give you the perfect summer glow to
shop hour in phoenix and see the
products like the marie one piece
offered in sizes small through triple xl
go to arrow and phoenix.com that's
a-r-r-o-w
and phoenix.com or you can follow them
on instagram
arrow and phoenix swim again that's
a-r-r-o
and phoenix swim fabulous check it out i
mean
check it out that is so person into the
situation a brand that has titties in
mind like that is just everything of the
source a swimsuit brand that has titties
i feel like we've gotten to a a good
place in the bra department
yes but the swimsuits it's so hard it's
so hard and it's like you want to look
cute and like if you have big boobs like
half the bathing suits
do not support your boobs and like then
you have neck problems and you're
walking around the beach
with like a humpback yeah it's it's
truly our cross to bear
it's truly our cross tomorrow fabulous
arrow and phoenix
okay first story big news of the day
still sort of a rumor but it seems like
there's some truth to it yeah so we'll
discuss all facets of it
the bachelorettes becca kufrin and
garrett yorogian
break up after two years together i had
absolutely no idea how to pronounce his
last name so you not know where i was
going to go with that no but like you
of course you're a scholar no no
according to my track record of
pronunciations
yeah you pronounced um tori lane's name
wrong yesterday
it's lanes what did you say it's lanes
and i said lines which is
really that's so you it's so me like the
majdijan you know you just making it
like french
yeah you know there's a highway in um
new york new jersey
it's spelled on the sign m a j
space no maj period because it's an
abbreviation for major deegan
well you're ruining maj
so when i first saw it when i i always
thought it was the majdijan
and i was on the phone once with someone
when i was in the car with olivia and i
was like
we were going to new jersey i was like
i'll be there sooner on the monash on
and
she was like what did you say i was like
i said we'll be there soon
it's major deegan it's major deegan and
even when i see it like it always takes
me a second to remember that it's
matched
on whoever sorry that is a major deal
ever since you like
titled it john according to me it is the
manchester chan now and it's just more
fabulous it's
so fabulous look at you just trying to
put a positive spin on a long drive
jersey yeah creme de la creme that means
cream fabulous time to remind you my
comedy special is still available don't
worry it will be there for you forever
and the quarantine if you're missing me
head over to amazon prime
apple tv type in disgraced queen or just
type in claudia ashrae
my comedy special will come up you know
i have to really stop promoting it
because like
it's everyone's watching it like i don't
even have to tell them but if you wanted
to just check it out
sometimes you need to be reminded
because there's so much content that i
put on my like content uppers list
that i forgot about you know i still
haven't watched the ben platt special
but if someone was reminding me
every day on the show that i loved her
watch it i would have watched it well
we're going on our trip and we're pretty
much not leaving our house and our house
is like a fabulous big movie room
and i think that we should just have
like a nightly event we need to watch
she's the man
yeah we need to make a list let's start
let's start like a google
content uppers list i don't want to
watch [ __ ] tinker taylor soldier spy
like i don't want to watch something
dark
i don't want to watch anything world war
ii like i would just like to keep it
light i'm trying to keep my mind afloat
okay okay fine let's get to this story
for once and for all
year again two years after falling in
love on season 14 of the bachelorette a
source tells e news exclusively
the couple's engagement is off in recent
weeks the reality tv stars were the
subject of split rumors
um and
sorry split yeah people before
speculating
people were speculating and there was a
lot of um
stuff on becca's podcast where she talks
about her relationship because it was
clear that they kind of have like
different
political views yeah you know before
quarantine i would have said that these
of all the bachelor people like i think
that they are going to make it like
their otp like i really felt strongly
about them
and then in the past couple episodes of
bachelor happy hour she's just been
alluding very vaguely
to you know there could be potentially
trouble in paradise
um and rachel was also very outspoken
about her dislike for garrett
and i guess it just turns out even
though like we knew this
before yeah because he had to like issue
an apology or something
um we knew before that like they didn't
align politically but i guess this
climate like you really just can't avoid
it especially if it's like in your own
house
if you disagree with someone politically
and and i feel like that's what happened
yeah enu says the conflict is part of
the reason why that they are going their
separate ways and
quote becca is still very upset with
garrett's comments and the controversy
surrounding it
their lifestyles don't mesh anymore
garrett wants different things and they
came to a realization that they aren't
compatible anymore
well she also left a comment on the e
news instagram who's this source
she didn't deny that the story was true
which is really what you do when you
comment on an e-news pick
yes so i think she read this story she
saw what this source is saying that
their lifestyles don't mesh anymore that
they're breaking up because of this
controversy
and she's like who's this source saying
that maybe that that part's not true but
the fact that they're broken up is true
also i thought maybe she was being shady
and alluding to her
the source being garrett there's no way
because um
garrett says the source says that
garrett is doing a backpacking trip in
the wilderness which is on his instagram
right now
he's with his buddies and is taking time
for himself they're trying to keep it
low-key because they're still working
things out but the relationship is
definitely done
so i think garrett is the much more
private one of the two of them
being in the wilderness like backpacking
yes buddies he's not calling up e news
and and spilling
i just thought it was interesting that
she like made a comment on it which is
really only something you do when you
want to like dispel rumors
not just comment on them you know what i
mean yeah
and so i went i was going through their
instagrams and it feels like all the
signs have been there for a while that
they're not together they hadn't posted
together since may i think
she had posted like captions talking
about her podcast and how she kind of
feels like she came up short
and in relation to her relationship with
garrett like she doesn't know
kind of where they stand or and so she
hasn't been
quiet about this so right no it's not
shocking it's not shocking i think
for sure the stuff that we saw with
politics can cause a rift in their
relationship but i also
think that there's more to the breakup
than just that yeah of course i mean
this is like now a conversation being
had and like i think a lot of people are
divided on
whether or not you can or should be with
us with someone who
you don't align with politically like a
lot of people i was reading the comments
and the comments on this post on our
instagram were very he did a lot of
people feel like
you know your politics really are like a
direct line to like your core values and
beliefs
and if that doesn't align with someone
like it's more than just politics it's
also like your
your beliefs like your whole belief
system and then a lot of people feel
like you should be able to co-exist with
someone
who is different politically than you um
i don't know i mean once again i see
both sides i think it depends on like
the
level at which you are political yeah
you know
and how much it is involved in your
daily life that's true
but i don't know i just feel like these
two
seemed really solid but then on the
other hand they were engaged for two
years and and
it doesn't speak of marriage to get
married but then on the other hand like
they moved to carlsbad california and
seemed like they were living like a
normal happy life honestly like the vibe
that i got was that like they
were so happy and that they didn't
really care so much about like the fame
and they just wanted to like live
together and they were grateful to the
show for bringing them together but like
this was like the end of their story and
like they were just gonna go and
live a happy life in carlsbad yeah but
then i guess like
this podcast sort of threw a wrench into
all of that and i feel like some people
feel like she broke up with him because
of what he said
and i think other people feel like he
broke up with her because she didn't
have his back
right which again both things are
possible
okay but then there's another layer to
this story because there is a rumor
going around right now
um it was posted on twitter by the
bachelor
suitcase guy is the account and long
story short he said that pretty much
like night one of tasha's new season
was pretty low energy and they didn't
get really the content that they were
hoping for
so the producers decided to fly in
hannah anne and a newly single becca
kufrin
and there's a paparazzi picture of
hannah anne walking into the hotel with
a suitcase
oh [ __ ] she's confirmed there but then
but reality steve says it's like you
know they bring in old people to like
give advice
right oh interesting but they weren't on
the same season that doesn't matter
by the way not to be rude like what can
hannah and give advice for like she
didn't win and she's not
she actually won but she didn't you know
yes um
and that newly engaged becca would be
there too and there would be a panel of
bachelorettes
and each week they would give roses like
the guys wouldn't choose allah
caitlyn and uh
but they would each be the bachelorettes
and they would keep like they would each
date all of these guys which is an
interesting theory like what if they
both fall for the same guy
then it's drama then the guy has to
choose and then the guy becomes the
bachelor right it's kind of like
bachelor in paradise but
less women more men um i kind of like
the idea in general
but the becca thing sort of throws a
wrench into it because that feels like
really soon
fresh i mean i like the idea as a show
conceptually like maybe as a spinoff
but to be honest like tasha is the
bachelorette let me just leave it at
that like
i'm really satisfied with that and i
think a lot of people are really happy
with it
and to to have her share the spotlight
when honestly she really deserves it
it's it's like annoying yeah it is
annoying and this whole like argument
that
night woman's low energy so they brought
in two more people i just feel like
again it's kind of like what we said
about e-news yesterday it's like
they made a choice and then they didn't
even give it time to like of course
their fruit
and of course it's going to be a little
hard to have chemistry immediately
because everyone's like what the [ __ ] is
going on yeah
they edit crazy [ __ ] all the time they
literally use
tear crying sounds from when a girl is
on the bachelor and they play it over
her
while she's on bachelor in paradise like
they can make anything seem like reality
they make mountains out of mole hills
all the time like why is this any
exception yeah and again i just can't
help but think like we would not be in
this position if claire crawley had
respect
i'm really like i'm continually annoyed
by it oh and oh my god
um oh also i meant to say spoiler alert
but now it's starting to feel like
they want us to know they want us to
know but also that spoilers are kind of
irrelevant because it's like we all know
what's going to go down sort of
it's all about how it goes down yeah i
just want to find this tweet
claire crawley went on twitter
um i remember when she released like a
series of tweets about how i think it
was matt james
was on cameo and she released a bunch of
tweets which was like first of all
like why do you care second of all i
just thought it was interesting
she finished off the this is just so
like full circle she finished off the
series of tweets to matt james but like
subtweeting him
respect the opportunity you've been
given respect the rules
respect me are you [ __ ] kidding
take your own advice girlfriend wow is
that funny and just like
isn't it ironic yeah it is ironic it's
always like
funny when people's own words come back
to write them but there's no way i mean
when you fall in love all the worlds go
out the window you know no not on a show
where you're
only meeting the person because of the
rules like just play the game it's two
more weeks
yeah but i i'm glad i'm glad for the
situation
season is sounding so interesting
whether it's just tasha and hannah ann
or if becca is there too which
to me really makes this whole thing seem
unfounded
yeah i've really actually come to like
really like becca a lot
i think she's like i didn't watch her
season that's when i was like done with
the bachelor
so i felt kind of disconnected to her
and just like now that she's on bachelor
happy hour and she's like
just been in the news a lot recently
like i think she's really pretty and i
like her a lot i like her too and
we always say the proof is in the
pudding and i think everything that she
did after
she was about to ride and got engaged
and she was really trying to have like a
normal life and also be an influencer
and she has her clothing line but she
seems like a a good person yeah and
i like her too um also one more thing i
wanted to say oh [ __ ] wait it was good
can you go back what would you say again
um her clothing line no
back it seems like she's a good person
she proof is in the pudding you never
watched her season thank you
so they've been engaged for two years
does she keep the ring yes i think so
sell it even though i don't know what
the retail value on like kneeling
jewelry is but
sell it yeah anyways i don't know the
stories i kind of said i thought that
they were
gonna make it solid me too but the
quarantine
is coming for everyone hell hath no fury
like the quarantine it's so true
nobody is safe nobody's safe we'll keep
you posted because this is still just a
rumor
it's not confirmed but it feels
confirmed
yeah but the bachelorette instagram has
been putting creepy like teasers out
and they keep showing it's like a rose
petal and then a pair of legs
so it was a rose petal and a pair of
legs and you assumed it was clear then
the next day they did one and you saw it
was tasha's legs
so i feel like maybe we're gonna get one
today and then it's like the three and
the first one was like becca or
something
because it's not clear anymore
interesting something to think about
something to think about
okay next story exciting news kiki
palmer is set to host the mtv vmas
2020 in brooklyn fabulous oh wait 2020
in brooklyn in person
yes so kiki palmer has been announced as
the host of the 2020 mtv
bmas which will take place at barclays
on august 30th
quote we're thrilled to have the
multi-talented kiki palmer as this
year's vma host
bruce gilmer president of music music
talent programming for
viacom cbs um said kiki is an energetic
force and a quadruple threat
with unmatched comedic wit who will make
this year's show truly unforgettable
the 37th annual vmas will take the moon
person into uncharted territory
as it's the first major awards show to
be held completely at a venue
since the pandemic began wow um there
was a
former in august 30th how
i guess so if there's performers uh bts
jay balvin and dojicat
and um bts sorry bts is making their
debut there but
i'm assuming that they're having
performers a host they're filming it
there's no one in this there's no fans
and there's no people to accept awards
and i i'm just gonna assume that
the exceptions will be like okay that's
a step
i'll watch it i'll take it i will i
would love to see a
full performance i mean i would i would
be watching even if it was virtual just
to see kiki palmer she really is a
quadruple threat
and i'm so glad like we as a society in
the last few years have come to
recognize her as a talent
because you know as children we've known
for years kiki palmer was a true talent
ever since
true jackson but i think it took the
adult world like a little bit longer and
i'm so glad she's being seen now for her
hosting abilities for
comic abilities acting singing dancing
it's fabulous it's just like you saying
your comedy special the cream always
rises
by the way and that is so true it's time
to make that up that's just good life
advice like if you're ever feeling like
you're looking being overlooked you're
being overlooked and you're everything
of the sword and
you're just not getting where you want
to go and other people who are sort of
like faking it
until they make it just remember the
cream always rises
and kiki palmer is the perfect example
of that like someone who just worked
hard
she seems like a really nice person
who's like professional and fun to work
with
and i'm just i like every time i hear
she got a gig i'm like happy for her and
they canceled straight and sarah and
kiki
i know and she was in an interview and
she said like she everyone like we were
just waiting for it to get canceled yeah
it seemed that way i watched what
happens live but she said that she has
exciting things coming up
she debunked the rumor that she would be
on the reel even though that was never
like a rumor was just like wishful
thinking no it was like a projection
like
maybe yep um and
she said she has exciting things coming
up and i think more than vmas but that
is the exciting thing coming up
it's an exciting thing coming up and i
feel like whoever is managing her
or her agents like do a good job because
they really use her talents she is
multi-talented she's a quadruple threat
which i hadn't thought of before singing
acting dancing comedy comedy hosting
you know there aren't so many of us no
they're singing
that's very okay i think i'm a quadruple
threat because i can't sing oh i can't
act for [ __ ] i'm sorry i'm a triple
threat
i can dance i am i funny yeah of course
you are
and i can host you a comedy podcast i
hope you're funny
yeah this podcast is funny i could say
i'm on it define
dance can could you say i could dance
yes you can you have rhythm and i bust
it down on the bottom it's a dance floor
like almost every night
okay so sing dance act
i don't know we're like not good
actresses no
okay sing dance comedy host
sex pot sex symbol sex symbol yeah
okay five we've got a quintuplet yeah
okay next story some
maybe new couple news that is
interessant jennifer garner
is pictured with bradley cooper amid
john miller split rumors
jennifer garner spent the day with
former alias co-star bradley cooper
amid rumors that she and boyfriend john
miller have called it quits
the longtime pals were photographed
having a beach day in malibu on
wednesday
a shirtless cooper was seen rocking a
mini man bun and red swim trunks as he
made himself comfortable in the
sand beside garner who was wearing a
sweater and a skirt
i saw a lot of people being confused if
they really thought this was jennifer
garner a lot of people thought it looks
like irene shake
his daughter's mom interesting i know i
thought it looked like her too but then
i saw people being like i think this is
irina shake but so i didn't i don't
think that these
like i'm reading this in page six i
started my newsletter this year i saw it
on tmz
i don't think that they would have
gotten that wrong i think this is an
absolutely sensational pairing i know
but they're like
a source full of page six that it's not
a romance that they've just been friends
and have been forever but that's
sometimes how some of the best romances
start
you have to have a foundation like a
friendship is a perfect foundation for a
romance
yeah i like them together i don't know
because here's i'm starting to become
really cynical about like celebrities
and these you know spotted beach picks
you know
because you we know at this point that
they know that the paparazzi is there
and that if they wanted to have a
private beach day as friends
they could have found a way to do that
and we wouldn't have known about it
yeah they want us to see these pictures
so why i feel that way
um about a lot of celebrities not really
bradley cooper
you know what i mean like i i agree with
you like when you see a paparazzi
picture and it looks like they've been
caught like more often than not like
their publicist called
bradley cooper is not desperate and he's
not thirsty for fame like he's
true true a-list and so is jennifer
garner she is
but we are always seeing like candid
photos of her she's always in a park
she's always she loves her kids so much
and
i feel like someone wanted us to see
this picture why
i don't know maybe they've just been
both been like a little irrelevant and
quarantined they needed a little pick me
up a little pr pick me up
maybe i mean it's a great pr pick-me-up
because it's like obviously anyone can
come out with a new romance and that's
exciting but it's a flame that burns hot
and fast and
yes and goes away quickly but like when
you're having just a great
friendship with two people who the world
like loves and respects
yes i don't know it's like a different
sort of pr move like
it's an intellectual one publicize my
friendship totally i mean i guess i
always forget like she
went through a lot with ben affleck and
now he he calls the paparazzi on himself
and added to armas
almost every single day this is where
we're getting okay
go back keep going maybe she just like
wanted something for her
herself maybe i don't know
like i agree i'm so cynical too and i
always assume
every paparazzi picture that you see is
coordinated like
very very rarely do the paparazzi like
hunt down a private celebrity
and actually get access to them like
more often than not it's totally
orchestrated and when that does happen
it's very clear that it's an invasion of
privacy
so yeah i just i don't see this for
bradley cooper and i don't see him
wanting to be associated with this
jennifer garner wanted it i think it
came from the garner camp
interesting well that's the last time
they hang out yeah no but i think he'll
see that like everybody's really into
this
i mean it's a great couple it's a
royalty a-list he also like does play
into these like check out my
my great friendship like with lady gaga
we're gonna let people think that we
have something going on
i mean he is actually a tease now that i
think about it he is
and this feels like they have a movie
coming out together
but there's no mention of that but watch
that's next oh yeah maybe this is like a
really like premeditated yeah strategic
move that'd be interesting i'd love to
see them in a movie together
i'd love to see jennifer garner back on
my screen always i'd love to see him
back on my screen
because like everything that he is in is
just inherently good
yeah and that way i would be seeing a
good movie
and i'd love to see good movies it's one
of my favorite pastimes
it is okay some exciting beauty news
megan the stallion is the new face of
revlon oh wow
the rapper was announced on thursday as
the new global brand ambassador for
makeup powerhouse revlon quote
i've always set the bar high for myself
with everything i do but to now be a
brand ambassador for revlon it feels
like a new level
she said in a press release to me the
revlon brand stands for both beauty and
female strength and i'm excited to
define what that means to a new
generation of women
and she's not just a pretty face she's
also seriously skilled in the makeup
department
she did her own makeup for the photo
shoot using all revlon products
this is one of the photos oh wow so cute
like sickening yeah
i mean this is this is huge like i
really can't believe
like how megan the stallion has like
popped on the scene and like really
taken off so fast
and we spoke about her yesterday i have
so much respect for her and this is
awesome
and i feel like she'll be on commercials
right that's what the facebook does
yeah hopefully well she did her own
makeup for the shoot presumably also
because of like the pandemic
yeah but i think it's like it is really
cool when people find ways to
take the situation that we're in and
like make what they're doing even better
because of it and i feel like this is
one of those examples she probably would
have had her makeup professionally done
for a revlon photo shoot
but instead we're getting to see how she
truly uses revlon products no totally
and i feel like
pretty much a lot of celebrities run
into the
beauty space because it is like a cash
grab it is
good money and to know that megan the
stallion a
can do her own makeup loves makeup and
clearly is very good at it
that makes just like a better more
authentic brand partnership you see
alicia keys announced that she's
launching a skincare line
yes did you see the james charles stuff
i did james charles
like posted like a shady tweet like i
wish people would just
like stop starting makeup lines who like
don't even like makeup at first i
thought it was about addison
because they're like best friends and
she just announced her makeup line right
then he deleted it and rephrased it
because he said i rephrased this because
a lot of people thought i was talking
about
my friends which i'm not and then he
deleted the whole thing
and he essentially thought that alicia
keys announcing
that she was doing skincare line was her
doing a beauty line well he
obviously just saw a headline that said
it was kind of misleading i think it
said like
you it's a beauty and when you see
beauty i think you assume makeup and
alicia key is
one of the many reasons why we
absolutely love her like vowed to stop
wearing hair and makeup
to like public award shows and just in
public life for like the last 10 years
and so anything shorter than that but
yeah whatever james has uh
was upset when he thought that alicia
keith was coming out with a makeup line
um and was just doing it like as an easy
cash grab
and like sub tweeted her and then ended
up deleting and apologizing one because
she's not coming out with a makeup line
she's coming out of the skincare line
and two and he said it himself he's like
why am i like the gatekeeper of the
beauty community like anyone is welcome
right yeah she's it's um a partnership
with elf cosmetics and
she has amazing skin and it's an amazing
partnership
she has amazing skin i will 100 and i
just
trust her like when she was hosting the
grammys and it was like the day that
kobe died like
i trusted her before but like i gave her
my whole soul then like i just feel like
everyone really like wanted to lay in
her bosom and just like
be caressed by her i actually recently
watched her cmt crossroads with maron
morris
how was it it was sensational like
i actually went on like down a rabbit
hole of a lot of cmt crossroads and for
those who don't know cmt crossroads is
this program that cmt the country music
channel
um puts together where they pair like
big pop stars and big country stars and
they do a small concert they sing three
of the country songs the three of the
pop songs
and you both you get to see like a fun
spin on a country song and a fun spin on
a pop song
and sometimes you can see like when they
just really don't care like i watched
the thomas rhett and nick jonas one and
like they just
they were just not vibing like for me i
watched jason derulo and luke bryan and
they got along famously like it was
fabulous
and with alicia keys i feel like she
really like learned marin mars
songs and like put her own spin on it
and it was like so genuine
and she was being so funny and they were
having so much fun up there and it was
really like a
fabulous pairing really really good i
highly recommend it's on youtube
oh that's so great have you seen katy
perry casey musgraves it was the first
one i ever saw of course i have it was
absolutely sensational sickening like i
don't know who did a better job
no it's it's so crazy and the craziest
thing about the two of them is that
casey musgraves was a songwriter yep and
she wrote follow your arrow and
presented it to katy perry and katy
perry was like this is your song you
should sing it and then casey became
an artist casey became casey i hope that
they have a good friendship me too
i mean that's a cute story the cmt
crossroads is so long ago like
they both look so different so much
could have changed so much could have
changed
and you never know but i feel like
they're neither one i mean well katy
perry was like involved in the taylor
drama but
neither one of them are really prone to
like beef yeah i agree
that's a good thing to watch another
content upper yeah i watched it over the
weekend it was just fabulous it was
entertainment it was music and it was
um very high quality well speaking of me
oh sorry and the one that i tuned in for
which was
unbelievable was zack brownband and
shawn mendes
it was so good snitch loves that one
it was like empowering wow speaking of
music
taylor swift on blake lively's daughter
in betty she said i named the characters
after my friend's kids
taylor swift recently introduced her new
song betty from her folklore album on
country radio and shared the meaning
behind her single
which revealed the name of blake lively
and ryan reynolds's third daughter
james has lost the love of his life
basically and doesn't understand how to
get it back
i think we all have these situations in
our lives where we learn to really
really give a heartfelt apology for the
first time she explained of the song
which uses the name of lively and
reynolds's eldest daughter james
quote everybody makes mistakes everybody
really messes up sometimes and this is a
song that i wrote from the perspective
of a 17 year old boy
i've always loved that in music you can
kind of slip into different identities
and you can sing from other people's
perspectives so that's what i did on
this one
i named all the characters in this story
after my friends kids
and i hope you like it she concluded
confirming that she used the names
of their daughters including inez as
inspiration inez
and is betty also one of the kids names
um they have three daughters
yeah so the kids names are james betty
anninez
they hadn't announced enos yet so now we
know that that's that their kid's name
is betty
oh sorry they haven't announced betty
yet so we had james and inez and now you
have betty
oh their his name is betty she just
announced it oh okay
sorry it's a little confusing it is
confusing i just don't keep up with like
honestly like celebrities kids names i
just feel like
they didn't name their kid betty but
they did and you know what i'm gonna
maybe it's a different friend's kid
i've no it's 100 those are the three
she's they have three daughters james
betty inez
okay right yeah um i'm gonna say
something incredibly controversial
and like honestly we might lose
followers because of it
you know what go for it i don't like
ryan reynolds and blake lively like as a
couple i find their brand to be so
annoying
and like the way like he's like cropping
her out of pictures like that's
funny like the way he's like mean to her
on twitter and like that's supposed to
be like funny like i just i don't
subscribe to their like love story at
all no i agree and i feel like we've
said that before and that's not new news
i just don't like them no yeah they i
and we
yeah no i agree with you there's
something about them that i just like
don't relate to
yeah and i'm just like not interested
thank you i'm so glad you concur yeah no
worries can we talk about real
housewives please
let's get into it not only was it an
amazing episode it was actually in the
right episode
but it was the 200th episode anniversary
and then we got
an absolute sensational watch what
happens live
with luanne celebrating it was all roni
themed it was
i've actually changed rouhoni to roni
because
andy said it like 500 times on the watch
robin's live last night and i realized
i've been saying it wrong my whole life
okay maybe i'll get there one day too
but it's annoying it doesn't sound right
rony okay rouhoni um okay but let's talk
about the episode of housewives first
and then we'll do watch travis live the
ladies are in mexico
um that night unfolds where luanne
is once again just victimized by dorinda
like in just trying to do her part first
of all
there were so many layers to that whole
fight ramona was being so nasty
to doranda who came down there to check
on her and do i think jorinda might have
a drinking problem
100 is that the time to talk about it
and be like to say it in such a nasty
way like you need to go to ia like
as if that's an insult ramona was so
wrong
but did she lie no
um so she was wrong there and then like
ramona's just being so weird like with
her
fixation on drinking water like she's
went through like a
like a lifestyle change and didn't tell
anyone like she doesn't want to talk
about vagina
she doesn't want to drink anything but
water and she doesn't want to be
associated with leah like
how when yeah i don't know i feel like
there used to be a time when it was like
ramona and sonia like drunken
and being funny and she has just totally
removed herself from that equation where
she doesn't want to be drunk and
and drinking like how she used to be
agreed she didn't tell anyone i don't
think that's necessarily a bad thing
that she's had that realization
but the judgment that she passes on to
everyone else like
isn't um fun isn't it it's not nice
and but i also do agree with you like
she's talking about yes in that instance
during the act she was trying to be nice
which is like a new thing rare
but she's talking about the general
landscape and she's not
wrong no and i just think like there
it's one thing if ramona wanted to make
a change in herself and like
she is you know of a certain age and
like her running around in a bathing
suit getting wasted like isn't
necessarily like the best look for her
i totally agree and i respect that and
her wanting to kind of rehabilitate her
image is one thing but to be so
judgmental of other people like
you're actually just doing less more
damage on your reputation because now
people think you're judgmental
and like you can be reserved and
conservative and not drink a lot
without shaming others for doing that
like that's where ramona loses me
yeah i agree she no she mostly loses me
also in like
really the um hypocrisy yeah like she's
always weirdly talking about sex and
like
yep it's like nobody asked for it she's
a hunchback who can't see her own hair
then when leah talks about it probably
just in words that ramona wouldn't use
but still talking about the same thing
like i don't think ramona says the word
[ __ ] but but sonia did at lunch she
said she had a chubby [ __ ] right
and nobody flinched like ramona just
when she was like running away from liam
was like no i don't want to hear this
like i thought ramona was about to say
like
i'm 60 plus years old like i don't want
to say that like i don't want to hear
the word [ __ ] and i would have been
like okay but she's like
i'm a good catholic girl but then like
they flash back to all the scenes where
she's worse
i'm not i'm honestly i'm not buying any
like any of what ramona's selling
no but it's weird because ramona's like
in certain situations like she's half
right
but no she's like 49 right and then 51
wrong and so she's
wrong and by the way her whole
philosophy and she's just
she's so hypocritical and even that
conversation with leah where they buried
the hatchet where i thought ramona was
finally like being an adult she couldn't
even recognize
her own hypocrisy and it was so
frustrating and i was really surprised
that leah just didn't [ __ ] lay into
her
because i don't know how you hold a
conversation with her it's just like
yeah rules are different
they're different rules for different
people there are different rules for
different times of day
and there's just like no consistency
when it comes to ramona and how to be
her friend and it's infuriating yeah and
then she just has like mood swings like
in the restaurant she just gets up and
they're having so much fun
they were having so much fun that was a
really fun night cute scene
i can't it's so frustrating for me like
jorinda
i like her sometimes like when she was
really defending leah last week and then
the early of this week
i was like so on her side but literally
like the way she treats
luanne is so insane and i think if you
really want to know like the
the nucleus of what's wrong with dorinda
is the conversation she had with leah in
the morning
she came in she tried to rewrite history
and then when leah actually pointed out
like luanne was the messenger she was
trying to help and you [ __ ] attacked
her for no reason
she like wouldn't have it like she's
so irrational and she refuses to
acknowledge even one thing that she does
wrong and like that
that whole conversation if you ever need
to know what's wrong with brenda like
just watch that conversation
she was so wrong she was so drunk lying
that she was drunk
refused to accurately uh describe what
had happened and was not interested in
hearing what actually happened from the
most
sober person in the room yeah she was
especially infuriating to me in this
episode and
i am at like a point with like i don't
i'm you i can't i honestly like i can't
stand
what she brings to the show she's so
cruel
the only person she's nice to is sonia
because she
only like cause sonia is and she keeps
trying to like bring sonia down and be
like sonia is going through so much
and a light energy energy and so like
great spirit
and drina's always trying to make it
seem like she's not doing well yeah
she doesn't want her to to be doing well
not only that i think dorinda for the
last couple years has really
successfully deflected
her own problems onto other people like
someone else is always going through
something but we're only down to five
women now
and clearly jorinda's the one going
through something she definitely has a
problem with drinking
she definitely has not properly grieved
the loss of her husband like there is a
lot to unpack there
and i think hers keeps saying like jiren
is going through a lot so
sonya's going through a lot is her
wanting nobody to realize that like
she's the one going through it but she's
acting so abhorrently like we have no
choice but to recognize like she's the
one
in a bad spot right and when she when
the conversation with luanne happened
and she was so wrong at first i was like
they're talking about how duran is
drinking too much and here she is like
being too drunk to even understand how
mean she's being and then the next
morning i thought
you know she would have that like drunk
remorse but like she was like i wasn't
even drunk so
okay are you what's worse are you
drinking too much or are you too mean
like yeah i mean to be honest i never
really liked dorinda and
she started to grow on me but she was
like a fan favorite for the last few
seasons
but like she got away with the most
abhorrent behavior i think
literally one of the most chilling and
polarizing scenes in the history of
housewives
of new york is the scene where she shows
up absolutely blacked out
to the dinner in miami with bethany and
her charity business partners before
flying to puerto rico to help
victims of the hurricane and she's
wasted fighting with the guy like
discrediting all of
all of his philanthropic efforts and
like this is bethany's business partner
it was awful and bethany was was harsh
with her but like that's what she needed
and like that whole thing just got
dropped because none of the other women
were there and like
there has been this pass for jorinda for
so many years when everyone is so quick
to call sonia and alcohol like literally
for her entire time on the show
look what happened to luanne do i think
luanne is an alcoholic no do the women
never let her forget what she went
through yes [ __ ] jorinda brunson
brings it up every episode
to be honest i think they all have
healthier drinking habits than dorinda
no i agree and i think that in this
in the scheme of of the whole thing like
who's the most right in the group and
who's the most wrong even though like
everyone comes from
for ramona all the time and like she
doesn't help her own case and she's very
flawed as a person
i think dorinda is like
the meanest the most problematic most
villainous
housewife in new york she's
self-destructive she's so
evil sometimes when she said i have a
turkey baster at home tinsley here go
have a baby
that was the worst thing i'd ever heard
in my life like seriously and nobody
even
didn't even get mentioned no it's crazy
like some of the i agree like
everyone's so quick to call out ramona
because she's a beast like when she
called them servants
she's an animal and she's really part of
like an older generation of housewives
that doesn't really exist anymore but i
feel like ramona doesn't get away with
anything when she does something [ __ ]
up she's constantly called out by the
group by the audience which
she should be like she has done even in
this episode like the
commenting on leah's mental health like
but everyone lets her know at every turn
why what she's doing is wrong and she is
forced to apologize and hopefully
learn from it every single thing that
does is just not even mentioned and
it's not helpful when luanne is like
clearly upset by dorinda and it's just
like i'm going to sweep it under the rug
because we're on this trip
no something has changed in luanne like
she
is so elegant like she really came out
of this season like as my number one
like
she's so rational she's so reasonable
she's so funny she really controls her
drinking
except it's frustrating to watch that
conversation in the cabana with
dorinda cause she just lets during the
roll right over her and like the reason
why
dorinda gets away with so much is
because more often than not luanne is
one of her victims and
she doesn't say anything yeah well so i
think this is what happened this is
what's happening with luanna maybe i
love her so much right now because
she's always been sort of polarizing
either like totally in the right
or totally in the wrong totally in the
wrong way like she's going through so
much we're going to stand by her yeah
but this happens with how's i sometimes
i remember it happened with lisa arena a
few seasons ago when it's like when
you're so used to being in the mix and
like
slinging [ __ ] at other people like it
gets exhausting and you kind of take a
back seat and you're on the sidelines
and you're like hey like this is kind of
nice not
having to go through it all the time
watching the other women go through it
and i kind of like being like
a sideline character right now and not
having like this burden on my shoulder
and the storyline be all about me right
i'm sure it's exhausting and
anxiety-inducing eventually
they get bored because they're rather
reunion and no one's really talking to
them they weren't part of the storyline
so then the next season they come back
stronger and i think that
did happen to rena i think she took a
break after munchausen and she just
became very like chippy
uh still funny and interesting but not
drama pot stirring
yes now she's back to drama pop stirring
luanne is is having that moment right
now where it's been a couple of rough
seasons for her where it's just like was
all on her back good
bad otherwise and now she's just like i
want no part of this i'm enjoying my
vacation in cancun yeah right and
you know what it makes you likeable but
you don't have longevity that way i know
but you know what sometimes you need a
break sometimes you need a break and
honestly i enjoy watching lauren i think
she's funny and like
i actually really like her and i really
respect her but see with
especially with new york the women have
so many personalities like
i have at times in my life literally
hated luanne like
i thought she was such a terrible person
for what she did to bethany on that
reunion when she called her lyanne
remember
and she accused her of having a
relationship with dennis who was married
like
i thought that and after all bethany did
for her like i was just i was so done
with her and now i just absolutely love
luanne
the women on new york really it's like
they wake up and they feel a certain way
and they're a different person that day
than they were the day before and it's
actually exhausting to keep up with it
yeah and you know what i've been
starting to assess like when i think
about which housewives i like and which
ones i don't like
i think about do i like their scenes
when it's just them like in their house
doing their regular life thing and
honestly for most of the women of new
york like no
no definitely not i really don't for
beverly hills like like i can watch
every single one of them in their home
scenes whatever they're doing like
i'm here for it also someone wrote this
to me recently i forget who it was just
um a viewer saying it's so interesting
because we're in new york and we're so
hard on the new york house and we think
it's like the worst show
yeah and they listen to a podcast of
people who are on the west coast and
they
love new york and they think like
beverly hills is the worst show no so i
wonder if it's just like i'm sorry it's
i i refuse
i know i know our critique of real
houses of new york has absolutely
nothing to do with the fact that we live
in new york i'll tell you what it has to
do with the fact
first of all there's only five of them
they're getting smaller every day second
of all
none of them have any money third of all
they're just there's no plot there's
just it's so inconsistent nobody keeps
up
there's a story line of a fight and it
fizzles out because everyone's either
wasted
or sobering up like it's exhausting
there's no real storyline there's no
consistency
honestly there's no real friendships
anymore like even sonia and ramona like
there's no real friendships and
why we love new york is they're rich
they're real friends
sorry new york but beverly hills
john why we love beverly hills rich lots
of money glamour fabulous trips true
friendships
on and off screen that adds to some of
the complications a teddy and kyle
on screen there's so much to unpack
husbands rena and denise
that's 30 years of friendship down the
tubes after two seasons the husbands add
such a fabulous element when they show
up
not that you need a husband but it's
called real housewives not any of them
even have a boyfriend on new york
yeah how did we get here i don't know i
i totally agree with you the show is
just
it's like irrational now and like other
shows follow
you know logic you said this you're
gonna be held accountable you said it a
few months ago to someone like even when
rina seasons ago said to
eden sassoon that uh kim was close to
death or yeah like
a comment like that on new york wouldn't
have even been remembered you know this
is this is the thing with
all other franchises like there is a
linear storyline
drama apology accounting ability yeah
like they're and morse
new york it's like fight drink sober
cry unrelated forget what someone said
to you the night before like
there's no consistency it's exhausting
it's like keeping up with a bunch of
maniacs yeah yeah it's a bunch of
maniacs
and and i'd like leah a lot but like
she's just not jiving with this group
at all no and like she can't save this
whole show we need
more lee as we yeah um just
more women who are new also because
these women are just so set in their
ways and the
viewers at this point have reinforced
their behavior yes and especially for
dorinda like every
viral moment she's had is when she's
being so mean so why wouldn't you be so
mean that means you're doing your job
right
and you know what you know what we need
and i'm sorry to be so fixated and i'm
like we need money
yeah it's an aspirational show it's
always been about the rich ladies and
how they live and like
these women like and ramona acts and she
said i'm watching live the other night
somebody makes 500 000
a year is not a lot of money ramona acts
that she has more money than she does
like she does not
and all of these women need the show
none of these women could
go off the show and just retire any of
the ladies in beverly hills
could live the exact same lifestyle
without the show
half of the women in new york would have
to move out of their apartments so i
think the thing with new york is that
it's not that they
don't have money because i think that
they have their housewife related
ventures they get paid
a good amount from the show because like
the four of them have been on for a long
time
but they all came like 20 years 10 years
ago from like these huge lifestyles
sonya morgan
dorinda luanne and they're using
all of the money that they make to sort
of like
keep these lifestyles but just like not
in the ways that
keep life interesting you know like
keeping a townhouse where
sonya could sell that townhouse and and
she shot
and by the way do you see the apartment
she's living in right now right that is
not the apartment of a real housewife of
new york i'm sorry to be like
so but that's what the show is it's
aspirational it's luxury
look at the potomac houses look at the
atlanta houses look at the beverly hills
houses even new jersey they all live in
super nice houses it's not the same yeah
so this has become less of an
aspirational show about fancy women in
new york than it has just about
a bunch of random women who happen to
live in new york and who are
love to drink messy um but the watch
weapons live special was
amazing i was like screaming at the top
of my lungs like they had so many guests
heather thompson cindy bar shop kelly
calor and ben simone jill zarin
the pirate showed up and confirmed once
and for all
uh andy and by the way luanne did not
know that any of these people were
coming she was genuinely surprised she
was like the guest but then they had
surprise visitors and he was like let's
put it to bed once and for all like did
you and len
ever mess around when you were in saint
parts and he said no yeah
part of me thought he was being he's a
really nice gentleman i think he's seen
the show he knows
his role on it that he's become this
character and he knows what it would
be to luanne if he had said yes and he
knows that she staunchly denies it
right so i think regardless of if they
didn't like did it or didn't like he's
just
a nice guy yeah he said he's like trying
to make it as a singer now in miami he's
so handsome when they don't have a
pirate like my jaw dropped i really
didn't think i could be like moved by
any surprise and then they did that rony
musical
that i loved i said i went to the
instagram account after and i watched
all the videos it's so good it's like
such a creative
funny idea that's well executed and it's
just fun
it was a really good episode and andy
you know
i i mean and i get it like doing a show
every night with like the same and like
from home
you really do get burnt out and you
sometimes you can see like andy's not so
into it but he was just like
excited and happy and like he really
loves the job
and they had so many fabulous throwback
moments especially to morocco they were
just talking so much about morocco
her and the camel yeah when they did the
flash they were doing the flashback of
luann on the camera like all night but
when they did the flashback of ramona's
face watching luanne on the channel i
was
laughing so hard it actually made me
want to go back and restart real
housewives of new york and i actually
did it once the first episode was
so long like it was just it was a truly
a different
era like the the cameras and everything
it's just like it's so blurry yeah
it's kind of hard to watch now but you
could start like in the middle i would
want to go to like
scary island i would want to see even
though even though that early season
where jill zaran bobby flies her down to
that trip with alex mccord and they kick
her out of the house like that's iconic
i feel like that's like season three
though still nice it's a little blurry
yeah it's so funny um the old housewives
coming back was hilarious it was funny
like who was trying to like overstay
their welcome oh yeah but you know there
was real you know there's a movement on
twitter for heather thompson to make a
return and i think you don't like her oh
no i love her i love her she was just
there's something about her she's so
smiley and happy and
she was always that way and when even
when she was just on her little virtual
screen like she was just like
um happiness off the screen i love her i
always really liked her i always loved
her i thought she was a great housewife
and she's one of the few who just left
and she was not fired like she just left
because like her time was up
yeah and cindy barshop was there which i
know you were excited about jackie sent
me a picture of cindy barshop on her tv
she's like it's your girl i'm like
what she's like you love her i'm like no
i feel like you're always bringing her
up like any time we talk about like
we go into the archives of real
housewives who like didn't make it
she's your first person okay i mean i
don't feel that way but if that's the
case that doesn't even mean that i love
her just means
it means i remember her name yeah which
is something for you
she was like a little wild on the on the
zoom last night
yeah she was she got it she upgraded
from quags to southampton
very exciting um so it was it was
fabulous i love those types of like um
anniversary episodes watch weapons live
like puts together these specials
sometimes and i think it's really
fun and special yeah i thought it was
funny i feel like luanne was just like
what am i doing here like why wasn't
ramona there like ramona by the way
luanne didn't even talk the whole time
and he was talking the whole time and
then all the guests were talking smiling
yes literally and she i think she had
fun but like she had no idea what was
going on
no and i why was it all on her no i mean
it was honestly a sign of respect i
think like the audience is really really
not happy with
ramona these days yeah and i think that
they just they listen like they're very
aware of what the audience
likes and doesn't like and i think that
them giving it to luanne was actually a
big deal
because ramona is technically the og
more so than luanne because there was
one season where luann was demoted to
friend of housewife
right but she's was still there and
we'll give it to her
and luanne right now i think is the
bigger star like with the cabaret and
she
is like the fan favorite of new york and
she's
reasonable and that's really all you can
ask from a housewife yeah
so that's our tv recap segment
unfortunately that means our episode is
over
so sad we will be back let me get the
actual date i meant to do that earlier
because i keep forgetting
oh my god theo just threw up oh my god
theo oh my you know he threw up last
night too oh my god
don't eat it theo the other oh my god on
our white carpet all right let's just
wrap it up
and then we'll clean up oh my god i'm so
sad i was ready to like it's okay you
don't have to clean up i'll clean up in
a minute i was ready to sit here and
shoot the [ __ ]
um wait let me take a picture of it for
my vet we've got it yeah
are you okay little man okay starting to
smell
sad it's starting to smell okay that was
just like an abrupt end to the show
guys oh i meant to find the date by that
really i'm like feeling really sad like
i want to cry but okay we are back in
studio
on september 14th so we will have five
episodes um until then every wednesday
so that'll include your toasters so keep
emailing deartoasters gmail.com
and enjoy the month of august try and
take care of yourselves try and be kind
to one another in the words of my
favorite host ellen
you know wear a face mask do a face mask
drink lots of water
and thank you everyone who's been
watching thank you to all of our health
care heroes thank you to every essential
worker truck driver
everyone who is just working wordlessly
helping
doing their jobs doing the best that
they can we see you we love you
and we will see you on wednesday not
that far yeah we'll see you in four days
[Music]
goodbye
you